let's make you a rendering pro
how am i going to do that well let me
break it down for you twin motion has
been on the market for a while now and
many people are using it for the base
purpose it was originally intended for
lackluster amateur renders when used
correctly from start to finish you can
compete with the best without having a
dedicated rendering machine a team of 50
or even a good design let's look at an
example these two images are from the
same program one is a basic export the
other is carefully crafted designed to
stimulate your senses and intrigue you
most people either don't know where to
start are too lazy to start or is simply
not confident in their abilities let me
teach you the skills right here right
now
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas welcome back to the channel that
was one hell of an intro i hope you
enjoyed it it took me more time to make
that 30 second clip that it usually
takes me to make a whole video but i'm
going to be stepping up my videos making
them better and better every single week
so make sure you subscribe for great
architectural content on this channel
now let's make you a rendering pro
first open up your browser on any
computer mac or pc make sure it has some
decent specs we can't be creating art on
a potato type in unrealengine.com in
your search bar find products and then
scroll down to twin motion scroll to the
very very bottom and get your free trial
hit the download launcher button and
then open up the launcher when it's done
again you're going to be looking for
twin motion and hit that install button
on the latest version caution preview is
not the full version it's just an
upcoming sneak peek look for the full
version if you want to explore in detail
i'll be using a reference file to
showcase the basics you can use whatever
is available to you if you want this
project file or anything that i create
here on youtube check out the patreon
link below when you first boot up twin
motion you'll see something like this
lackluster right down the bottom you'll
see five icons import context settings
media and export two triangles in each
corner left for everything you need
right for everything you've already made
a little creepy big brother eye with
even more icons and a full screen button
next to it that's the ui done on the
left everything is self-explanatory
click drag drop done same method to
apply or change materials once you
change them a new menu appears tweak
this to make it perfect after you've
repeated this process most likely ten
thousand times added a couple trees some
cars and maybe some people it's time to
be a photographer media image create
image
under the image title you'll see more
format 4k just changing this will
increase the quality of your image 10
fold finally adjust both the lighting
and camera settings to how you like it
and hit export think you're done nope
adobe non-sponsored plug seriously break
the bank and open lightroom drop your
export in apply one of my presets you're
welcome and export photoshop edit sky
replacement pick a sky save it and
you're done anyway that is all from me
today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video i
hope you like the fast-paced upbeat a
little bit more intriguing a little bit
more enjoyable type of content than i
usually produce if you did make sure you
smash that like button for the youtube
algorithm and if you really loved it
make sure you subscribe to the channel
every single week there is a new video
on some form of architectural content or
technology if that's something that is
interesting i would truly appreciate it
if you join this little community but
otherwise like always i'll see you next
monday